[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain an american science fiction
action film called logan's run
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the premise of the movie is set in the
year 2274.
the world has been torn down by a
holocaust and the surviving humans live
in a utopian domed city the city is
inhabited by an idyllic society where
there is little to no work and people
are free to pursue all of the pleasures
of life the residents of the city are
governed by computerized servo
mechanisms and there are no human
leaders the computer takes care of all
aspects of life including reproduction
as no humans are allowed to reproduce
sexually however there is a catch
a person can only live up to 30 years of
age before undergoing the right of
carousel and being terminated the
computerized servomechanisms enforced
this rule to manage the population and
keep it constant but they have made the
residents believe that the people who
are terminated in the carousel are
actually renewed and brought back to
life as babies
this is basically like zoomer buddhism
some people called the runners have
caught up to the fact that they're being
lied to by the computers to stop them
from running away from the city elite
policemen called the sandman are
appointed to track people's age each
person is implanted with a life clock
crystal in the palm of the left hand at
birth the life clock changes color as
they get older and begins blinking as
they approach their last day
the protagonist of the movie is a
sandman named logan v but unlike the
usual sandman he is curious and
questioning in nature in the opening
scene logan 5 is in a laboratory looking
at artificially born infants one of them
is named logan6 who he donated sperm for
his friend and colleague francis 7
brings him out and takes him to that
month's carousel event several people
who have reached the age of 30 are going
to be terminated and a crowd is gathered
to witness the right it is noticeable
that the people are wearing either red
yellow or green clothes indicating their
ages red for the older ones green is for
the middle aged and yellow is for the
teenagers the sandmen wear their usual
black uniform
at the beginning of the ceremony some
masked people in white gowns are brought
to the arena and circled around a giant
lotus
following that the platform they are on
begins to move around creating a zero
gravity zone the masked people float in
the air and are killed one after another
as the crowd cheers when the right is
almost over the sandman are alerted
about a runner trying to escape from the
west entrance they chase him across the
facility and eventually shoot him off a
balcony logan 5 scans the man's face and
does a quick identity check before
leaving he confiscates the runner's
belongings that include a small metal
ankh the abandoned dead body is then
vaporized by a modern device logan 5 is
confused why the man didn't renew
instead of trying to run away but his
friend francis 7 dismisses it the
sandman are given lavish apartments and
are considered the elites of the new
society logan 7 is in his apartment
drinking at the end of the day by
pressing a button he summons a girl for
his pleasure the girl is named jessica 6
and is fascinated by logan's apartment
he gets her to the sofa and tries to
kiss her but jessica rejects him she
doesn't want to get close to him because
she is grieving the death of a friend
who is terminated that day
logan dismisses her concerns stating
that her friend was just renewed but
jessica scoffs at the comment claiming
that carousels are death not renewal
logan gets suspicious of her being a
runner and inquires about her age
jessica quickly proves that she is young
by showing him her life clock which
hasn't turned red yet
they're interrupted by francis who
arrives with two girls on his arms
looking to have fun jessica quickly
rushes out of the apartment saying that
she shouldn't have been summoned the
following day logan goes to the sandman
headquarters to report the confiscated
objects from yesterday there he finds
out that the ankh is a special key that
the runners use to get their secret
hiding place called the sanctuary the
computer informs him that over 1 000
runners are on the loose currently and
instructs him to catch them all a
confused logan asks the computer how
many of the runners have been renewed he
begins to suspect that the renewal
program is fraud when the computer
doesn't answer instead it orders logan
to be a runner in disguise and help them
catch the others he again retaliates
claiming that the life clock on his palm
will give away the disguise to his
surprise the computer removes his
remaining four years of life so people
would believe he is a runner logan
protests but it goes in vain because the
computer turns itself off now he only
has some days left to live and a mission
on his hands
he returns home and summons jessica
again believing that she knows something
about running he tells her he only has a
few days left to live and shows her the
ankh that is identical to the one she is
wearing around her neck jessica accuses
him of killing a runner for the egg and
storms out believing that logan is
setting up some kind of trap it is
revealed that she is part of the runner
group herself when she tells her friends
that logan knows about the sanctuary
they order jessica to finish logan once
and for all she brings logan down to the
arcade but before she can kill him he is
informed of another runner the two get
into a vehicle and chase the runner they
end up in an area filled with cubs
people who are deemed unfit to live in
the main complex because of their wild
nature the cubs circle the two intending
to rob and kill them but logan uses his
weapon to chase them away
next logan uses his scanner to scan the
area and locate the runner they were
looking for he finds her within seconds
but instead of arresting her he lets her
go out of sympathy because of this
jessica drops her plans to kill him and
starts to believe he is genuinely a good
person as the two continue their journey
to the sanctuary we see francis kill the
runner that they just spared he now has
seen logan and jessica get out of the
cube's zone
knowing that the sandman will eventually
catch him logan goes to a medical
professional to get a facelift to
disguise himself however during the
procedure the doctor gets a call from
the sandman and turns against logan he
pushes some buttons and uses his face
lifting device to attack him logan
reacts quickly and manages to avoid the
machine's attack francis arrives at the
clinic and gets into a fight with him
but logan and jessica somehow manage to
escape
then they run to a tunnel and meet the
other runners on their way jessica's
friends do not trust logan because a
sandman turning into a runner is unheard
of but they agree to let him go on when
a nurse from the clinic earlier confirms
that logan is on their side the two are
told to follow the tunnel to reach the
sanctuary right then a group of sandman
arrives with their guns blazing the duo
manages to run away but is followed by
francis
they eventually reach a door that
requires the egg to open it jessica
tries to get hers from her necklace but
it falls into the water and gets lost
logan quickly uses his to open the door
and go to the other side when francis
comes following them he finds jessica's
ankh and continues the pursuit
meanwhile the duo is lifted up by a
machine to a frozen cave they are
approached by an ai robot called the box
whose job is to capture food from the
outside world in order to feed the city
the robot is about to freeze them into
food but logan uses his gun to fight him
eventually the cave starts to fall apart
and the two run into the outside world
they are mesmerized by the beautiful
scenery in front of them they have been
so brainwashed by the computers that
they don't even know what the sun is and
they call it a hot ball
after walking for a while they sit down
to take a rest not realizing that
francis has followed them outside as
well
the following day jessica and logan are
tired of walking and are still looking
for the sanctuary they eventually reach
a pond and decide to take a swim jessica
finally gives in to logan's efforts and
the two make out they also see that
logan's life clock has stopped
flickering meaning that the clock
doesn't work in the outside world and
they can maybe live for as long as they
want
later that day they notice a tower and
happily approach it thinking it must be
the sanctuary but they are soon met with
disappointment to see the tower and the
buildings around it have been taken over
by nature suddenly a cat brushes over
jessica's leg startling her the couple
is fascinated to see an animal for the
first time they're sure to be
disappointed when they realize that cats
are [ __ ] they follow it and reach a
classroom with an old man inside they're
both amazed by his wrinkles and gray
hair as they have never seen a person
that old in the city the man says that
he has been living there since the
holocaust and didn't even know that the
city existed the duo also learns that
the old man was raised by his parents
unlike the residents from the city who
are made in a laboratory and raised in a
nursery suddenly francis arrives and
holds jessica hostage holding her at
gunpoint he asks logan to get closer so
he can terminate him but logan manages
to divert his attention by asking him to
look at his palm francis who somehow has
yet to look at his own hand is as
surprised as the others to see his life
clock not blinking but even then he
doesn't want to believe he has been lied
to his whole life he attacks logan and
the two get into a fight the struggle
ends when logan manages to wound francis
gravely by hitting him with a pole logan
then holds his old friend in his arms
and wishes him goodbye as he dies
following that the old man makes the
couple bury francis's body in a grave he
claims that he buried his parents around
the same area because that is what
humans are supposed to do logan wants to
go back to the city to show the people
that there is so much more to life than
artificial lighting and dying at 30. he
thinks that the residents will believe
him if he shows them the old man as
proof the next day the three of them
leave for the city while resting on the
way the old man explains the concept of
marriage and family to them good thing
he didn't also tell them about the
divorce rate or they'd have abandoned
their plan then and there they
eventually reach a hydro plant that
supplies water to the city logan asks
the old man to wait for them for as long
as he can before the couple jumps into
the water and swims back to the city
logan finally tells the people about the
outside world but no one cares the only
people who hear them are the sand men
who arrest them logan is taken to an
interrogation room where the computer
asks him if he found the sanctuary when
he doesn't answer they use a technique
called surrogation to look into his
subconsciousness and download data from
his mind however the vast knowledge of
the outside world is too much
information for the computer to process
and it starts to malfunction maybe logan
did learn about the divorce rate after
all everything controlled by the
computer starts to explode including the
facility they are in
the city is ruined making the people run
outside in fear everything controlled by
the computer starts to explode including
the facility they are in as the domes
are destroyed the people are introduced
to the outside world for the first time
they see the old man and are amazed by
his wrinkles like jessica was they
surround him asking if they can touch
his skin
the movie ends as jessica and logan wave
at the man from the crowd indicating a
happy ending
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching